Images from earlier today of
barricades being erected
near the courthouse
where the grand jury
investigation into the former
president is taking place.
More security cameras are also going up.
And we mentioned earlier
the fears of violence
from his most fervid followers
after Trump
wrote on
social media to, quote, protest,
take our nation back.
There is also the question of
how do you protect a former president
during such an unprecedented
and historic moment and time?
I'm joined
now by our senior crime and justice
correspondent, Shimon Prokupecz.
Shimon, what more
can you tell us about the timing
regarding the potential indictment?
And how is law enforcement
preparing for such a potential moment?
Yeah, I mean, there's
so many different dynamics
at play here, Pam.
When you think about it,
you have a former president, a
never before
in the history of our country
have we seen a situation like this.
Then you have potential protesters.
You have the fact that law enforcement
is thinking about
what happened
on January six
and what they may have missed back then.
And so
all of that is factoring
into the decision
making that's going on here
from federal law enforcement
to the New York City
Police Department, state
and other
federal agencies
who have all been in meetings
for the last several days.
One of the things that certainly
is very concerning was the posting,
the social media
posting by the former president,
sort of calling on his followers
to take to the streets to take action
that he was going to be arrested.
Tomorrow, we're getting indications
that that is actually
absolutely not true, that
the soonest
or the earliest
that we could see the president
if he was to be indicted
and we don't know when that would be
or if that would even happen
would be next week.
That's what law enforcement
is working on
right now, that his initial court
appearance would be next week.
So everything and all of that is playing
into what law enforcement here
is going to be doing
in terms of increasing security
around the courthouse,
bringing in barricades,
bringing in more cameras,
and, of course,
bringing in the former president
into the courthouse.
That is the number one
priority for the Secret Service
to ensure his security.
And that in sort of his arrival here
at the courthouse,
which could happen next week now.
So a lot still at play
as law enforcement tries
to figure out the logistics
of all of this
and protecting the former president.
And obviously,
anybody who comes out here
and the court staff
and the people who live around here
and work around the park.
All right.
So stay with us, Shimon,
because I want to bring in CNN
senior law enforcement
analyst Andrew McCabe,
a former FBI deputy director.
So, Andrew,
as we mentioned, over the weekend,
the former president called for protests
ahead of a possible indictment.
What is law enforcement bracing for
if he is charged?
Well, Pam, I think,
you know,
if you're a security professional,
a law enforcement professional,
you have to begin
by assuming
that the president
still has the same sort of sway
and influence
over his supporters that he did
leading into January 6th.
So they are taking all the steps
that many would argue
should have been taken before
January six.
I'm sure they're looking
very closely at social media.
They're trying to understand
if there's chatter out there online
and those places where
the former president's
most extreme adherents go to
to exchange messages
and things like that.
I would expect
that my former colleagues at the FBI
are speaking to their sources
of information and informants
in those communities to tap
into what sort of interest there is.
And in convening in New York
or any other place around, a potential
arraignment and charges.
And New York is
relying on their deep experience
in crowd
control is no place in the country
that does it better than New York City.
I'm confident that they'll be
they'll be well-prepared.
They'll take whatever steps are necessary
to avoid what we saw
happen on January six.
Do you think, though, indeed,
that he still has the influence
to mobilize
far right supporters
like he did on January six?
I think you have to assume that he does.
I mean,
you know,
this is a very different sort of event.
I mean, the lead up to January six,
the president
and his supporters had many days to talk
about coming to D.C.
There was a date certain
that they needed to be there.
That all facilitates
organization and transportation
and funding for people
who want to come and attend.
And they also had the cover,
if you will, of a legitimate permitted
assembly at the Ellipse.
So those are all things
that don't really add into the mix here,
which I think puts law enforcement
and security professionals
in a little better position.
But they have to plan for the worst.
That's their job.
There's so many questions.
Shimon,
that we're asking for the first time
because of the unprecedented nature
at play here.
If this happens,
is there any word in terms of logistics
on how Donald Trump
would appear in the courtroom
if he is indicted?
Everyone expects him to appear here
like any other defendants. Right.
So the Manhattan DA's office,
when there's an indictment,
they then notify the defense attorneys
for the
for the defendant, for for the person
who is going to be arrested
or that a person appears
at the district attorney's office,
which is just behind me, where they are
processed, fingerprinted, photographed,
and then they're brought over
to the courthouse, usually
the Manhattan DA's office.
You know, they walk the defendant
through the halls of the courthouse,
into the courtroom
for all of us to see handcuffed.
We don't think
that's going to happen here.
You know, for many reasons.
But we certainly do expect
that he'll be here.
But I do just want to know
one thing, Pam,
that in terms of social media postings
and threats,
I've actually spoke
to a law enforcement official today
who said
they're seeing actually that
things are pretty quiet
on social media
and nothing like the run up
on January six.
They've been running down things.
They've been sort of questioning people
who are posting suspicious things.
But so far from everything
that they're seeing,
while there may be a lot of noise,
there's not a lot of concern for them
right now.
Biggest concern is getting the
the former president here safely.
And that is something
that they're certainly working on.
All right, Jim Prokupecz, Andrew McCabe,
thank you so much.
Well, sometimes lost in the headlines
about the president,
the indictment or his party's
reaction to all of this
is the story of the woman
at the center of this alleged cover up.
Stephanie Clifford,
who goes by the name Stormy Daniels.
CNN's Tom Foreman has all those details.
He had a hit television show.
She was in adult films.
He was 60.
She was 27
when they met at a golf tournament
in 2006,
where Stormy Daniels says Donald Trump
shared photos of his wife,
his new baby boy.
And you had sex with him? Yes.
And Trump has denied it ever since.
And to be bringing up that kind of crap
and to be bringing up witch
hunt all the time,
that's all you want to talk about.
Born in Louisiana,
Stephanie Clifford
got into adult entertainment
in her teens, taking the name Stormy.
By her account,
she thought Trump might help her
get into TV.
Instead, her allegations of an affair
took over the headlines, a key claim
as Trump's 2016
campaign came to the wire.
She says she was paid $100,000
to keep quiet about him.
He denied any knowledge of
that in the spring of 2018.
Did you
but that same summer,
did you know about the payments?
Later on, I knew.
Her story has seemed at times confusing.
For example, at one point
she signed statements
denying any affair took place
if it was untruthful.
Why did you sign it?
Because they made
it sound like I had no choice.
I mean,
no one was putting a gun to your head.
Not physical violence now.
You thought that there would be
some sort of legal repercussion
if you didn't sign that?
As a matter of fact,
the exact sentence used was
They can make your life
hell in many different ways.
Further complicating questions
now at the Center of the legal case
against Trump,
did the alleged payoff
come from campaign funds,
and was that a violation of campaign
finance laws?
Former Trump lawyer Michael Cohen,
who went to prison over
that alleged
hush money, says yes
and that Trump knew about it.
But others in Trump's
orbit say no way
that money was not campaign money.
Sorry.
As for the former president,
just days ago,
he leveled an insult at Daniels
as he insisted once again.
I did nothing wrong in the horse
face case.
Never had an affair with her.
Witch hunt.
This story has been unwinding for years
and it is now
full of many twists and turns.
But it may finally now be time for
a court to sort it all out.